[موسيقى]
اول شيء يعني مثلا مرحله الطفوله كنت ارسم
فيها كثير كنت مميزه طبعا
في مدرستي اني من وانا صغيره بيسموني
فنانه المدرسه
الشرقيه
اول ما درست بالرياض
سنه اولى جامعه كان كنت في سكن الداخلي
للطالبات بعليجه كان ما شاء الله لدينا
مهتمين يعني فينا كثيرا كان في قسم
الانشطه فانا دخلت النشاط الفني وشاركت في
معرض
كانت هذه اول انطلاقه لي يعني شفت
فيها ردود الناس
تجاهها اعمالي
[موسيقى]
بدايه الفن التشكيلي اي فنان يبدا بتعلم
كيف يستخدم ادواته كيف يبدا
الرصاص والفحم ثم الالوان ثم لازم يجب ان
يكون لديه اسلوب يتفرد به
المراه كعنصر اساسي دائما في اللوحاتي
تمثل التراث انا كثير يعني مهتمه بالتراث
والموروث الشعبي تحديدا بالسعودي لو
سالتني لماذا
صراحه خلال شفراتي
تقريبا ب 2008 سافرت الى احدى الدول
الخليجيه
وزرتها هناك متحف بالمتحف رايت اهتمام
كثير بالموروث طبعا انا بالمنطقه الشرقيه
وكما تعلم
الجزيره العربيه كبيره
ومرت بها حضارات كثيره
تقريبا تشمل يعني المنطقه العربيه من
العراق شمالا الى جنوبا عمان
منطقه حضاريه واحده
فتتشابه كثير
وجدتهم يهتمون كثيرا بالتراث والموروث نفس
اللي لدينا لكننا مهتمين فيه ومتمسكين فيه
يعني مسني شيء من الغلط
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]